et nous prenons tout de suite la
direction de marioupol dans l'est de
l'ukraine où nous attendent notre envoyé
spécial julien chez id à bourg jours
julien on va parler avec vous de la
situation sur le terrain dans le donbass
après la reconnaissance des républiques
séparatistes de dounia dessus de loin
aux par vladimir poutine avez vous des
informations d'abord sur les mouvements
de troupes russes dans la région
et bien ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'au
cours des dernières 24 heures il a
effectivement eu des mouvements troupe
l'autre de l'autre côté de la frontière
entre la russie et la région du donbass
mais à l'heure actuelle il est
impossible de savoir si c'est si ses
troupes et bien se dirigeront vers mario
paul la seule certitude que nous avons
pour l'heure c'est que les troupes
russes qui sont dans la rive dans les
régions séparatistes de donetsk et de
l'eau entre occupe environ 30% de ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le dôme basse
sur la ville de maillots paul pour
l'instant nous n'avons pu constater au
que nous n'avons constaté aucune
activité militaire ni d'armes
ukrainiennes et encore moins d'une
éventuelle arrivée de militaires russes
pour l'instant on peut dire que dans la
ville c'est le calme plat et justement
alors l'atmosphère à marioupol et les
habitants de cette ville sont sont
inquiets
oui effectivement si les gens essayent
de vivre le plus normalement possible si
c'est calme ici eh bien on a noté une
certaine fébrilité depuis quelques jours
je vous donne un exemple ce matin il
était environ 10 heures lorsque nous
étions avec des ukrainiens qui nous
accompagnent dans notre séjour et nous
avons entendu des déflagrations très
lointaine et d'un seul coup les deux
ukrainiens avec qui nous accompagnent se
sont arrêtés se sont regardés pendant
quelques secondes se sont demandé ce qu
il est possible qu'il s'agit de
déflagrations qui est ont lieu sur la
ligne de front puisque nous sommes à 20
km de la ligne de front et donc c'est
les ukrainiens se sont arrêtés et
ensuite la vie a repris son cours autre
exemple nous étions ce matin en surplomb
du grand port industriel de marioupol
nous voyons au loin un navire dans la
brume un ukrainien s'est approché de
nous a demandé si nous étions en train
de filmer l'arrivée de navires
militaires russes il s'avère qu'en fait
c'était un navire un navire marchand qui
n'avait rien à voir avec la russie donc
tout ça une certaine fébrilité que nous
avons constaté au cours des dernières
des dernières heures merci beaucoup
julien chez id a envoyé spécialà à
marioupol